willkommen im hasenuss Wunderland wir
haben vor kurzem einen alten Bauernhof
gekauft und im Garten stehen ungefähr
zehn riesige hasenussstreucher wir haben
nur drei Stunden gesammelt und schon
waren drei große Eimer randvoll brauchen
me Eimer h fand die Nüsse auch richtig
lecker und auch wenn Hase nüse für Hunde
nicht giftig sind dachte ich mir die
Schalen runterzuschlucken kann doch für
den Bauch nicht gut sein deswegen haben
wir ihr welche geknackt und weil wir
unsere Nüsse später mit einer
handkurbelkackmaschine knacken haben wir
die nach Größe sortiert sonst müsste man
nämlich nach jeder Nuss die Maschine
umstellen aber bevor wir mit dem Knacken
anfangen breite ich die Nüsse im Haus
immer erstmal aus zum Trocknen hier habe
ich so eine kleine Brotbackform Barriere
gebaut damit sich die unterschiedlichen
nussgrößen nicht wieder vermischen und
irgendwer ich fürchte das war ich hat
beim Sammeln ab und zu die Hütchen an
den Nüssen gelassen die musste ich als
erstes also noch abfriemeln weil die
Nüsse sonst im Lager faulen können Nüsse
lagern sich übrigens am besten in der
Schale also am besten knackt man die
erst bevor man die wirklich braucht